[Musique]
il y a de plus en plus d'écran tactiles
dans les cockpites d'avion il semble
présenter certains avantages mais
sont-ils véritablement efficaces ou
sécuritaires des experts se penchent sur
la question
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue à bord
du vol 2042 à destination du futur
des boutons des manettes des cadrans il
y en a partout et surtout beaucoup
l'opportunité auquel les avions font
face présentement cette capable de
réduire le nombre de dispositifs de
commandes à faire du poste de pilotage
oui on veut réduire le nombre de boutons
mais aussi réduire l'équipage
au début ils étaient cinq ensuite quatre
puis trois aujourd'hui ils sont deux
pendant longtemps le pilote était
responsable de voler l'avion de faire un
rôle de conduite pour piloter l'avion
avec l'augmentation de l'automatisation
à bord la plupart des tâches de vol en
fait sont prises par l'autopilote et
maintenant faites le rôle du pilote
évolue aussi donc il passe d'un
conducteur à un gestionnaire de mission
qui doit travailler en équipe avec
l'automatisation et l'autopilote
nous sommes dans un hangar à Montréal
Philippe Doyon poulain et son équipe
imagine le cockpit de demain en ce
moment les écrans tactiles font le
apparition dans le poste de pilotage
puis c'est vraiment un enjeu d'actualité
pour tous les manufactures d'avion
[Musique]
pour tester l'efficacité et la facilité
à passer une commande sur un tableau de
bord on évalue différents outils de
contrôle un manche un bouton rotatif un
écran tactile et un clavier numérique
donc maintenant les écrans tactiles font
leur apparition dans les postes de
pilotage et ça soulève des enjeux qui
sont propres à l'aviation c'est à dire
l'écran est fixé sur le tableau de bord
et il se trouve à bout de bras du pilote
pour pouvoir faire l'interaction donc ça
soulève des enjeux à cause des problèmes
de vibrations
d'accessibilité de fatigue cet appareil
est vraiment loin d'un poste de pilotage
nouvelle génération en fait ce
stimulateur reproduit les vibrations
auxquelles le pilote est confronté ce
qui intéresse Philippe Doyon poulain ce
n'est pas le confort mais plutôt
l'ergonomie cognitive l'ergonomie
cognitive c'est de la psychologie puis
de l'ingénierie qui sont combinés
ensemble à terme notre objectif c'est de
concevoir des systèmes de commande ou un
poste de pilotage qui soit facile
d'utilisation qui correspondent la
manière que laquelle le pilote voit
comprend et agit sur le monde donc on a
besoin de ces deux disciplines la
psychologie et l'ingénierie procurer de
concevoir un poste de pilotage qui est
plus sécuritaire et plus efficace pour
nos pilotes
[Musique]
une trentaine d'étudiants sont soumis à
une série de scénarios parfois facile
parfois complexe le participant reçoit
des instructions à peu près à toutes les
5 ou 10 secondes qui lui demandent en
fait de d'entrer une nouvelle valeur
soit de vitesse d'altitude de cap puis
on va mesurer la performance du
participant dans ces différentes
conditions avec les tous dispositifs
auxquels on accède
maintenant ce que c'est difficile pour
la précision qui requise en fait tu vois
le nombre de fois il faut faire un
défilement avec le doigt pour atteindre
la bonne valeur ce qu'on évalue c'est sa
vitesse de réaction et son taux d'erreur
en fait on s'intéresse beaucoup à la
présentation de l'information à
l'interaction et aux dispositif pour
aider la prise de décision de nos
pilotes la plupart de nos tâches ou que
le pilote est confronté se détache
cognitives donc de prise de décision
d'évaluation d'options d'anticipation de
jugement et clairement il faut adapter
les outils pour faciliter ces tâches
cognitives
pour cela le participant porte des
lunettes spéciales et ce n'est pas par
coquetterie elle permettent de suivre
son regard pour mesurer la tension ce
qui nous intéresse en fait c'est capable
de voir combien de temps est-ce que le
participant a dû observer notre
dispositif d'entrée de données ou au
contraire ont été capables de se
concentrer sur la tâche de vol
donc c'est des données qui nous sont
disponibles grâce à l'appareil de suivi
de regard donc l'intention ici c'est que
c'est qu'on veut minimiser le temps avec
lequel le participant va regarder notre
dispositif d'interaction on veut qu'il
soit capable de passer plus de temps à
voler l'avion
[Musique]
avec ses travaux Philippe Doyon poulain
aimerait que le cockpit du futur puisse
jouer un rôle encore plus important la
grande question où s'arrêtera
l'automatisation du cockpit
tous les manufacturiers sont en train de
regarder comment augmenter
l'automatisation afin d'être capable de
réduire le nombre de pilotes donc pour
être capable de descendre à un pilote en
ce moment avec l'intention est capable
de voler sans pilotes
un avion sans pilote un jour la
technologie va le permettre maintenant
reste à savoir si l'humain lui sera prêt
pour une telle aventure la réalité c'est
que j'ai peur en avion et ironiquement
donc j'ai toujours peur de monter à bord
d'un avion aucun doute le premier vol
commercial sans pilote se déroulera sans
lui
il restera les deux pieds bien sur terre
pour préparer l'avenir
[Musique]